make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so we are picking up
with
uh batman the joker war part two
part dos and here's here's a funny thing
man like i feel like james kenyon's
killing it on batman which my bigger
question is why didn't they slap him on
batman before
okay so the cool thing about this is
that this initially picks up in gotham
city right and we're just kind of given
this idea that it's years from now right
some point in the future but basically
like
you have what amounts to almost kind of
like this future futuristic
version of gotham right i mean it's it's
almost like a utopia it's like what
metropolis is right it's sunny and it's
beautiful and it's not crappy and
thunderstormy the way it is now so
basically like it's not seattle but
basically like you've got batman chasing
down the freeze family
now it's kind of weird one because of
the fact that every time i see the name
victor freeze i always think of victor
fries
and two because he's got kids right one
of them is called
like snow cone and it's like and the
other one's like ice pop sagar james
hitting we got to work on your name
scheme
a lot of this kind of seems to be
individuals or young kids who are just
kind of wrapped up in victor freeze and
taken to be as you know more or less
like proteges i mean as far as i'm aware
nora doesn't have the ability to produce
children unless he made him using
you know her dna or something like that
but regardless batman takes him out
pretty quickly and then we switch back
to the bat cave right like the kids are
basically being shunted off so they can
receive some kind of treatment and bruce
wayne's an older guy and it's kind of
wild to see him that way because my
initial thought was
okay so like superman became batman
basically which is kind of a kind of
weird thing but he's called master bruce
so it's it's bruce wayne and it's kind
of nuts right because we're given this
idea that like
gotham is everything batman wanted it to
be that it's this beautiful
utopian place where crime is a is an
almost non-existent
concept you do have a few criminals who
pop up every now and then but instead of
gotham being this terrible cesspool of a
place where all the worst possible
things could
and do happen then instead it's any city
everywhere that has some measure of
crime right for the most most part it's
a great place just a few bad apples
the problem with this is that it's all
an illusion because immediately alfred
just kind of starts losing his mind his
neck snaps he's got the joker grin and
he's like this whole thing is lies
you're gonna die alone with no family
with no one to love you you're gonna die
a lonely miserable life right like
batman's biggest fears and then he snaps
up right it's not back to reality as
eminem once said like he snaps right
back up and he's basically just kind of
recovering from this toxin that he was
hit with by punchline now that's kind of
the crazy thing
because the toxin that she used is
wildly potent and that's what makes it
so wild i wouldn't go as far as to say
batman has like
an inherent you know immunity to like
the fear toxin of the scarecrow but it's
something that he's used
to and to have it impact him in this way
where he's been out for days
is kind of nuts right it's kind of wild
now of course harley quinn was the one
who saved him you know harley quinn
looking the way she is she was she's the
one who saved him and of course she you
know more or less had herself stitched
up you know from her injuries but with
the three days that he's been out batman
kind of asks what's going on
gotham has descended into absolute
madness and i
absolutely adore the way this has been
done by james tinion right because my
fear
i'll be honest with you guys my
legitimate fear going into this when
tinyon was like well here comes joker
taking over gotham it was going to be a
repeat of end game right where he just
like floods the city with joker talks
and everybody goes crazy
i was afraid that's what was going to
happen no not at all instead
joker's there but it's really kind of
punchline who's running the show and for
the most part the various gangs of
gotham have all unified under the
ideology of the joker right so they're
all basically joker gangs they've
basically taken batmobiles turn them
into joker mobiles joker cycles joker
planes the whole nine yards like all of
batman's gadgets and
and uses have been handed over to the to
the joker crowd the other part of this
is that people are basically just kind
of fleeing for their lives as best they
can
the whole city's turned into madness but
you do have a few instances of people
who have taken up arms themselves
it's kind of a cool thing to see right
the people are basically just taking up
arms to protect their city as best they
can and ultimately that's what it runs
into in this kind of situation that it's
only when things are at their absolute
worst that people will actually get up
and stand up for themselves right that
if they have somebody there to protect
them to keep them safe they'll rely on
them
almost all the time but for the most
part like any scenario we would expect
the city's madness you basically have
people who are running a muck
under the mantle of the joker versus
what few people here and there are
trying to do what they can to keep
themselves safe
almost everybody else is just hiding in
fear and that's why you know batman kind
of asks like where's the joker on all of
this and that's where harley responds
the joker's not really the one running
the show all the time a punchline is the
one running
most of the show that's going on the
underbroker basically has his lawyers
keeping the city at bay right so in a
lot of ways
it's kind of the dark knight returns
right instead of it being bane that
cripples the city of gotham it's the
joker who's done it by taking all of his
resources and all that kind of stuff now
i know there are huge parallels there
but to be honest with you guys just
based on what we've seen with gotham
being the way that it is
i actually kind of think this is better
and so from there harley ends up
revealing that the joker kind of has
like this you know
joker bot of ad time basically in the
city of gotham because we know
you know with news companies and so on
if the money's there they don't care and
so what you end up having is basically
just like the joker running ads
all the time on tv with the same kind of
thing right the guy that you thought
died right the old man who ran the
theater who apparently didn't know who
the joker was which is kind of weird
aziz was carved onto his face which is
pretty gruesome and he tells like this
amazing i mean it's it's not funny
but it is a thrilling tale of adventure
romance and vengeance a story of a man
reborn as a hero a story of
the symbol he would use to mark the
world the mark of
zorro remastered and better than ever
this is the gotham cut
only three people saw the inning last
time and it changed the course of the
city's history
what happens when everybody sees the
real ending the mark of zorro now
playing
back to back sold out screenings at the
monarch theater wide release is only
days away
coming to every movie house in gotham
city and like as he reads this off it's
like prepare for the final shot he's
like no please like the joker shoots him
it's not
funny but it is
[Music]
this is why i love the joker man of
course this this brings back terrible
memories for batman right like monarch
theater and harley grabs him and kind of
snaps them out of it right and it's kind
of cool to see that like harley quinn's
the one who's trying to pull batman back
from the edge like you would think it'd
be selena kyle in this instance but at
the moment
it's harley right selena kyle bailed out
right it's harley who's trying to pull
him back
and it's interesting to see because you
don't really see her in that light the
closest i think i ever really saw to
harley quinn in this way
was during the new 52 batman run by
scott snyder when she approached batman
and told him like joker's not who he
used to be now of course that was after
she hit him with a sledgehammer and
knocked him into a vat while she was
wearing a red hood mask you know she's
like you know joker's not the same that
he used to he's not the same old mr j
like he's he's different now
there's something different and twisted
about him now that wasn't the same way
it was before
i feel like that's the closest we got
but one of the things she says here this
is what's so cool she's like you can't
go
out there right now and do all this
you're not in the mindset to do it
you've still got this toxin running
through your veins you still gotta let
it work out of your system
if you go out there now and you get
yourself killed then like we're all
gonna die
right so it's interesting to see harley
quinn in this position to where she's
like beseeching batman to stay behind
because he's the only one that can
really keep them alive but the cool
thing about this is batman finds a
method of control
and that's what i think makes the fear
toxin so incredibly potent right because
when you're infected with this toxin
your imagination becomes your enemy but
for batman he's a wildly focused
individual and what he does is focus
all of this into the voice of alfred and
so it's kind of like alfred comes back
in this regard that batman knows alfred
isn't there and he knows he's not real
but letting the fear toxin take the form
of alfred's voice
is one kind of focusing the sphere toxin
in a way where it's not nearly as potent
and two putting it to use because he
becomes batman's conscience
and that's kind of what alfred was right
he was the voice in the back of batman's
head that was guiding him when he wasn't
always there letting him know what the
right thing to do
is and so of course with everything kind
of going down you know people being
cornered by these these you know gangs
and so on and so forth batman basically
leaps in takes a few of them out and
then kind of goes
goes about right i mean batman's not the
kind of guy where he would like look at
these people being attacked by the joker
gangs and be like best of luck
here's a batarang you got it and then
just and just take off batman's gonna
fight those guys off and then you know
continue on his way to the to the
monarch theater but as he gets in there
it's a horrifying experience for batman
for a variety of reasons right one
because the mark of zorro as most of you
guys know was the movie his family went
to go see when you know of course they
were shot and monarch theater was the
theater they were coming out of so this
is like a a terrifying experience for
bruce wayne now at this point in his
life he's basically passed it you know
his parents death is really more of a
means to achieve a particular goal as
opposed to the thing that
that kind of haunts him and keeps him
down and so what he ends up doing is
once he gets in there the whole place
smells like death right
rotting flesh the whole nine yards
everybody in here is basically dead and
it's a wild scenario because joker pops
up and he's kind of like when batman
asks a question like why are all these
corpses here right like they look like
they've been decaying for years the
response of joker is because they have
right
this is our fam this is everyone that
i've killed in the pursuit in this cat
and mouse game that you and i have going
on
everyone who's been a victim of mine and
what i've done is i've given them a kind
of toxin
i've given them a substance that will
reanimate them in effect
joker creates his own zombies and sends
them all after batman with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you